hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasting
I'm just checking in on you guess why
I'm in I'm in my [ __ ] garage where
every goddamn married guy gets sent
every other [ __ ] day it's [ __ ]
unbelievable I can't remember the last
time I actually just got to stay in my
house and it wasn't some [ __ ]
something coming over could you not do
your podcast in the bedroom what why
can't the plumber is coming in he needs
to plumb some plumbing oh well what a
plumber is gonna get offended by my
[ __ ] language it's unbelievable
banished [ __ ] banished I'll tell you
right now you know I don't want to get
into it I'm gonna get into it they're
all warriors and they're all [ __ ]
victims anyway well I'm glad you guys
you guys really seem to enjoy that
podcast I did with Paul virzi I got a
bunch of already call him [ __ ] emails
and [ __ ] telling me yeah you know that
was the fastest 90 minutes of my life
and speaking of which we have a new
podcast email then Monday morning
podcast at gmail.com that's where you
send all your questions all your
comments all your criticisms all your
fields man Monday morning podcast at
gmail.com and by the way Paul virzi this
weekend's gonna be at levity live all
right if you enjoyed the goddamn free
podcast why don't you go out and spend a
couple of [ __ ] dinero's out there and
go see that guy he's [ __ ] out there
crushing it you can say you saw him at
the club level when he would still meet
and greet people after his show but I'm
telling you right now Paul virzi it's
gonna be when he [ __ ] makes oh when
he makes a little bit of money there's
something white coming into his world
it's going to be either a couch a
Lamborghini a leather jacket it's going
to be something
angelic white he did something the other
night when we went to this [ __ ]
Lakers 76ers game right and like that
two top guys Joelle and Beebe and the
other [ __ ] guy didn't even play you
know it's the worst gonna be like your
games so [ __ ] worse by the time the
game starts the Stars the other team are
so [ __ ] exhausted from banging
[ __ ] models and [ __ ] that they don't
even show up to the game even if they're
out there so you know whatever we're
[ __ ] sitting there watching the game
and then afterwards we went in and there
was a VIP area we could actually smoke a
cigar in the [ __ ] Staples Center
which I did I smoked my first cigar in
like 50 days but now back to just not
smoking so I've and I do I have no
desire to smoke them or anything like
that so I kind of I got myself off him
so now it's just like alright the next
time I'll smoke one will be next month
in April going to going to another
sporting event and I imagine I will have
one there but I'm really thinking like
it maybe not so that's how that would be
like I would like my relationship with
cigars to be so he was sitting there we
were sitting there in this little
[ __ ] room smoking cigars there was no
smoke eater so we were in this [ __ ]
giant cloud and there was this crazy
Russian dude there right you know all
five foot seven of them and he's just
[ __ ] you know jumping into any
conversation you know he's had a couple
of [ __ ] to three cocktails so he's
failing and he's failing conversational
right so at one point I was just like I
was just talking to this old Laker fan
who actually knew the game which is a
very rare thing to find I don't know
where the [ __ ] they all are it's usually
just you know you know you're a hater
Celtics are [ __ ] like they just don't
talk the game and this guy could
actually talk the game so having a good
time talking to him I was like you know
I got a bit you know I can't stand the
Staples Center just how far away the
fans are how quickly they get pushed
away from the action and now the forum
which I went I saw the Kobe Shaq Del
Harris and I want to say Dennis Rodman
was on that team to us
way back in the day over 20 years ago at
the old forum you know there was no
upper deck it just went from the floor
just straight up like an old college
Stadium and you were on top of the game
and it was loud and I was going I just I
just don't like these newer buildings
and then the Russian guy goes you know I
would actually argue that and I looked
at him I said you know what I'd agree
with that right I don't know why I said
that I got you know what I agree with
you you don't even need to present your
argument I agree with you
right and then everybody laughed and
then he proceeded to make a point
anyways even after I just said I agree
with you he makes a point anyways about
the new Staples Center I just said you
know that's very interesting you've
completely changed my point of view I
never looked at it that way I can't
believe I was gonna walk around the
world without that information thank you
so much for sharing with me everybody
was just I found this new [ __ ] thing
because that for the first time in my
life I think I didn't get sucked into a
stupid argument I was gonna sit there
and argue architecture of a sports arena
with some drunk Russian guy in a
four-seat little [ __ ] cigar area with
no smoke eater so like three more times
I say something and this Russian guys
like you know I would argue that and I
just kept going you know what did I
agree with you oh now you are [ __ ]
with me it's just like nice don't argue
remember my first cigar in two months I
just want to sit there enjoy it I want
to [ __ ] say they're talking about
foundations degree of arches and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] one you don't know anything
about stadiums neither do I do you like
the Staples Center
congratulations why the [ __ ] do I want
to ruin it
so anyway was sitting there in virzi
well you know talking about whatever and
we brought up this one guy and whereas
he just goes he goes Christ you question
is there something wrong with that guy
and then my buddy goes I don't
understand how you mean that and he goes
is there something wrong with that guy
[Music]
it's one of the most italian things i
ever saw him do he made a statement the
listener didn't understand it and asked
him to rephrase it and he did while
using the exact same words only an
Italian can [ __ ] do that is there
something wrong with that guy how do you
mean that is there something wrong with
that guy change the inflection and he
moved his shoulders a little bit
differently I [ __ ] laughed for like
10 minutes it was just go what what did
i do what did I do
anyway we had a great time and you know
I don't know those [ __ ] the LA Games
always stink they just [ __ ] suck you
know what I mean the only times I've
seen I saw that the big three Celtics
they came out here and I'd watch them
lose to the Clippers they come out here
and they go out and they they [ __ ]
bang some [ __ ] celebrity and they're
all [ __ ] out before the games start
I'm telling you if the [ __ ] Bruins
come out here and they play back to back
they got the Ducks and then they got the
kinks I'm telling you do not go to that
second game they'll try on the first one
then the second when they're all they're
all [ __ ] out so there's one a few
gamblers out there and they always do
you know they try to have the team stay
down in Hermosa Beach it doesn't matter
horse half cars they go down there and
they just did you yeah that's what they
do they just [ __ ] them that's that's
anyways that's just my stupid theory Oh
March 10th everybody Dean del rey's Bon
Scott tribute at the Avalon in Hollywood
all right do not miss out I'm gonna be
doing some stand-up there playing some
drums
Dean's doing his stand-up then he's
gonna be singing with the [ __ ]
all-star band doing the entire if you
want blood you've got it live album from
ac/dc on the 40th anniversary of the
death of Bon Scott one of the great
frontman in rock and roll history now
let me ask you this if you don't want to
be a part of that then I think you need
to get the look at that I was having
such a good time I forgot to do the
advertising all right got to record it
on my phone here we go butcher box
everybody oh these guys are my favorite
when it comes to quality
meat quality matters but there's more to
it than texture and tastes better for
you better for the animal better for the
environment well I don't know what the
animal still ends up in the same place
what's your favorite cut of meat how do
you like to prepare it grill cast iron
skillet broiled etc I like the pork
chops and I like brown it up in this do
you know what I do I put it brown it up
on the skillet I stick it in the oven I
finish it in there and then I bring it
back out little garlic rosemary butter
bath right now about that luckily
there's butcher box luckily there's
butcher box butcher box believes
everyone deserves high-quality humanely
sourced me never be without something to
cook for dinner because there's always
meat in the freezer
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection to each
box has nine to eleven pounds of meat
which is enough for 24 individual meals
unless you're a fat bastard and you'll
probably finish them at 6 I can
customize my box or go with one of
theirs it's the best meat shipped right
to my door which means one less trip to
the groceries they already made that
point options like 100% grass-fed and
finished beef free-range organic chicken
and my favorite the heritage pork
wild-caught salmon you don't know what
they're gonna do and sugar nitrate free
bacon butcher bucks is the most
affordable and convenient way to get
healthy humanely resourced meet with
butcher bucks you get the highest
quality meat for just six dollars a meal
I think they've said all this and they
even have free shipping nationwide
except Alaska and Hawaii right now while
Alaska doesn't need it they're killing
their own foxes right now butcher box is
offering new members ground beef for
life that's two pounds of ground beef
and every box for the life of this
subscription plus $20 off their first
box just go to butcher box.com slash bar
or enter the promo code bar at checkout
that's butcher box.com slash bar b you
are r or enter the promo code bar at
check out alright lastly but not leastly
it's honey you know that honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart and you
know how great it feels to save but how
does it feel to save with honey saving
with honey
feels like sliding into the seat on the
train just before the door doors closed
at night I don't wanna slide on anything
public transportation hitting every
green light on your commute I like that
finishing up your podcast episode right
as you walk into work
feel free to insert your own example
here putting on your jacket without
blowing out your shoulder sorry that's
an old man thing personal endorsement
please interject a personal experience
of how honey has saved you money if you
recently saved on a gift for someone
mention that for instance what did you
buy that honey saved you money on
fashion technology gadget travel how
much did you save be specific example
forty three dollars and seventy five
cents on a video baby monitor how did
you feel when honey saved you money
example surprised excited
something fantastical etc about honey
choose one bullet point to feature slash
discuss hope if I talk all through that
I don't know how to use a laptop I would
love to use honey sounds like an amazing
thing honey has found it's over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings did you know honey
how could you supports over thirty
thousand stores online including Macy's
tag it
Sephora Best Buy and more and they're
adding more every day users love honey
that's why soda bears that's why it's
one hundred and I'm talking about gay
men that's why it's one hundred thousand
plus five star reviews on google chrome
store using honey feels pretty great
think of it it's a little daily victory
plus it's free to use and install just a
few seconds get honey for free yet join
honey calm / / that's join honey dot-com
/ / alright I messed up there's still
one more stamps.com the ones who started
at all who sits around wishing they were
at the post office oh not me
that's why you need stamps calm you can
do you can do everything you need to do
at the post office on your computer you
heard me talk about stamps con they've
been sponsoring this show for over seven
years now and if you haven't tried it
what are you waiting for with stamps
calm you can save five cents off every
first clap stamp up to 40% off shipping
rates that kind of saving really adds up
especially for small businesses plus
stamps calm is completely online which
saves you time no more inconvenient
trips to the post office are having
to deal with the morons in LA traffic
whether you're a small office wait
whether you're a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or even away how a warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
time isn't the only thing you'll be
saving with stamps calm you can get five
cents off every first-class stamp and up
to 40% off shipping rates there's no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitment stamps calm is a no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
over 700,000 small businesses are to use
stamps calm right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free but postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps calm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that
stamps.com enter bird people have been
sending me a lot of [ __ ] about the
coronavirus saying is this what you
wanted or and all that it seems to me
like it's the flu there's a new strain
of the flu out there I think we're all
gonna be fine
you know what I mean I understand it I
and I think it's great that they're
canceling a lot of these public [ __ ]
events like Coachella and that type of
[ __ ] it's just like what why yeah let's
just let the thing burn itself out it's
gonna be fine and I love when I see
people wearing those [ __ ] you know
end-of-the-world masks that's great I
love that there's somebody doing that
out there because what if you have it
great now I'm not gonna get it or if I
have it I don't want to give it to you
I'm a team player but I'll tell you what
it isn't gonna work is the [ __ ]
self-imposed quarantine self quarantine
like some [ __ ] douchebags that's like
Evans self arrest no ankle bracelet you
stay in your house here for six months
okay see you later
scouts honor human beings are too
[ __ ] selfish and they get bored too
quickly for any sort of self quarantine
all right we have to go like China okay
everybody stay inside for [ __ ] a
month let's let the air clear up if you
go outside you're getting shot that's it
okay everybody freaking out what about
people like this what about people like
that and as a reasonably healthy human
being you know what I say I say what
about them what about them it doesn't
affect me then I don't care
sorry I'm trying to get in step with the
politics today alright here's another
thing that I wanted to discuss here
MotoGP starts this Sunday the greatest
racing on the [ __ ] planet I cannot
wait what's gonna happen who's gonna do
it
huh is it gonna be is it gonna be
Andres Davitt CEO so I watch this great
thing on Jack was it Jack Miller I
watched a great little documentary on
him and the sacrifice that his family
made so that he could race really
amazing really amazing well I'll tell
you something else Australian guys are
funny his dad's funny like the way he's
like walled off from his emotions it's
very like [ __ ] old school you know
reminded me of my dad like yeah you know
you do what you do and you know that's
it you went through this unbelievable
hardship can you get it can you talk
about it well you know as yeah
definitely a difficult time but you know
I I do it again we had to do what we had
to do but now it was you know that's
what happened me and Rosie we're having
such a great time talking the last time
that I didn't get a chance to read some
of your questions here so I would like
to do that right now all right here we
go
I had this [ __ ] hilarious
conversation with this guy right he was
saying he was talking about Trump and he
was going like Bill he goes what bad
thing has happened Trump says Trump has
been it I'm like all right well first of
all you're a white guy so I mean you
know your life never changes no matter
who's in there you're not on the fringes
all right you're right in the middle of
the [ __ ] pack galloping along you're
not the Illuminati level white person
where your where your life could
actually get even better or get slightly
worse you're just in the middle of the
pack you know he's just going like you
know our economy is doing great it's
like dude we're bankrupt
how would how are they moving the
numbers now that they don't count that
twenty trillion dollars and he's like
you know he goes as much as black people
don't like Trump they are working more
than they've ever were it's it's
according to I cannot [ __ ] believe
this I'm just beside myself but I'm
beside myself that a [ __ ] I'm talking to
a white guy and he's telling me what's
happening with black people how the [ __ ]
do you know
first of all with unemployment don't
they stop counting you after like six
weeks they're like hey he's not looking
for a job [ __ ] him
white or black or Asian or they's he
goes what the what what has bad is hella
I don't know he thinks global warming's
a hoax
took us out of the Paris agreement I
would say that's probably a bad thing
you know publicly said that there's two
sides to every story when there was neo
Nazis involved I mean could I just I
will never [ __ ] be able to [ __ ] and
have a conversation with somebody that
is so blue tie or so [ __ ] red
telecall it's [ __ ] up people who are
blowing the Obama's is their drone
bombing wet weddings you know I mean he
just has this energy and this magnetism
I don't I don't [ __ ] get it they're
all on their knees blowing the bankers
and wiping their tie their mouths off
with their [ __ ] red or blue tie
that's what the [ __ ] they're doing and
then when they're done being president
they all go out and tap-dance for the
people that paid them off so they can so
they can get their [ __ ] their hush
money in the form of public appearances
[ __ ] unbelievable I I don't do this
well maybe I do this a lot if you sit
around and all you do is watch CNN or
all you do is watch Fox News you are a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not watching news
you [ __ ] [ __ ] what you're seeing is
the results of deregulation
where one person's [ __ ] opinion can
then infiltrate half the [ __ ]
population that's what the [ __ ] they
were trying to avoid that's what people
saw coming
and these underpaid politicians so they
could get their big [ __ ] house in
their boat after the fact you really so
[ __ ] up it is that after you're
President of the United States for eight
[ __ ] years you still have to go out
and do a tour you don't have any [ __ ]
money
un-fuckin'-believable
it's almost as dumb as watching the left
trying to impeach Trump and it's like
are you guys out of your [ __ ] mind
do you see the guy standing right behind
the guy you want you want that pen sky
Jesus Christ that guy sends chills up my
spine [ __ ] serial killer look in his
[ __ ] eyes you guys are out of you
just keep the dope with the toupee keep
that guy in there trying to get rid of
him and then you sit there how many
[ __ ] times are the people gonna pick
Bernie Sanders and the dumb Democrats
are gonna wheel another [ __ ] company
man with banker jizz on the side of his
[ __ ] mouth to [ __ ] step in there
for you again un-fuckin'-believable I
was so hoping that it was gonna be
Bernie Sanders against Donald Trump
because just for the pure entertainment
okay any top scientists the same with
this global warming it's already too
[ __ ] late right so just for the
[ __ ] entertainment before they pull
the plug on this whole thing I mean the
[ __ ] pay-per-view level of Donald
Trump vs. Bernie Sanders debates you
know I just I think that would be a
fitting way for us all to go out right
just two old guys yelling at each other
I don't know sorry I'm getting a little
dark here
all right let's get to some happy [ __ ]
so by the way so if I run into you on
the road I don't want to hear your
[ __ ] political opinion it's it's like
talking to a sports fan who just watched
somebody on his own team slewfoot
somebody and then try to say that it
wasn't a [ __ ] penalty and then when
the exact same [ __ ] thing happens to
his team that guy should the other guy
should be out of the [ __ ] leak all
right I don't I don't get it all right
Rocket Man didn't believe in Flat Earth
everybody hey bill that dude that took
Flat Earth money because that dude took
Flat Earth money because he was broke
that's [ __ ] awesome he never really
believed it was flat some of my friends
do though there are some convincing
convinces arguments but I'm not sold
watch a few minutes of Flat Earth dock
on YouTube and you'll see what I mean
some stuff about the official story
doesn't make sense
lots of weird explanations about the
laws of gravity do you guys ever think
you're just too [ __ ] dumb you know I
love when like you're gonna sit there
and you're gonna second-guess [ __ ] that
[ __ ] scientists and astronauts did as
just some [ __ ] guy who goes down to a
[ __ ] sports bar and order some wings
no I'm not wasting my time doing that I
have one for you why don't you save up
your [ __ ] coins and go on a trip
around the world fly around the world
and take out your smartphone and just
stare at the compass the whole [ __ ]
time and watch yourself go west and come
back around to your [ __ ] house again
all right I actually want to read this
because I want to know where does the
Sun go huh because if it's a flat earth
now the sun's moving is that what I'm to
believe or are we tumbling on this flat
piece of [ __ ] on a log
[Laughter]
that's another one too
these [ __ ] [ __ ] watching
documentaries you know something that I
do a lot but just you know people just
[ __ ] will sit there and be like did
you see the Courtney Kurt Cobain
documentary I do it I think Courtney
killed Kurt I'll do you is that what
your police work told you as you sat
there eating a [ __ ] hot fudge sundae
and your goddamn pajamas
I'm not even this mad right now at any
of this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about
anything I'm just [ __ ] pissed for
that feel like the 90th day in the road
I have to get the [ __ ] why am i leaving
why am i leaving why do I have to
[ __ ] leave hey Bill don't be too loud
in your own house [ __ ] unbelievable
all right let's talk about some other
country Ramazan everybody who I used to
[ __ ] take advertising money for I had
no idea they were like this Amazon taxes
built big fan have been for a very long
time thanks for being so damn hilarious
and please consider doing a few shows at
Comedy Works in Denham Denver sometime
you're the only comic I've never seen
play there I play there a zillion times
I'm actually doing a date in Denver
coming up in September I forget the name
of the venue but it's gonna be listed
soon all right anyways he said I'd like
to share an article with you about why
Amazon doesn't pay taxes because that
claim is a half-truth well I never said
they didn't pay taxes the truth is while
Amazon paid no federal income tax it did
pay over half a billion dollars in
payroll taxes well that's only because
they can't get out of that and over a
billion dollars in local and state and
international taxes and the reason
Amazon paid no federal income tax the
company was playing by the rules that
Sanders and his cowboy Sanders and his
colleagues in Congress created can I
tell you something nobody really creates
anything
Congress because what was Bernie Sanders
voting on I never hold any politician
like when the other side goes oh this
person did this it's usually it'll be
like do you want to stop sudden infant
death syndrome
and then you be like yes and then
there's a bunch of [ __ ] attached to it
which I don't understand while they're
able to do that so then that's that's
your baby literally that's what the [ __ ]
you trying to get past and then they
they they put these other attachment and
then we can stick a [ __ ] oil line
under some sacred Native American burial
ground and then when the election comes
along it's like so-and-so red tie or
blue tie voted for this all right but
evidently it was Bernie Sanders and his
colleagues in Congress created in an
effort to encourage businesses to invest
in research and development and to take
risks in creating jobs
well phrase that way I'm sure that they
did it because they're never gonna get a
hundred percent what they want because
why would these Americans do that here
they don't they want to be here and then
not [ __ ] pay taxes Congress
deliberately wrote the tax law so that
development costs and past losses would
would reduce the tax burden on
businesses that took chances and
survived just read that they they if
they actually have to pay somebody a
fair [ __ ] wage they won't be able to
buy as big a yacht as they want all
right
the [ __ ] out of here with these [ __ ]
taxes that that's why they're not here
they're they're exploiting slave labor
around the world and we can't compete
with it now you could say the unions in
this country eventually drove them into
that move I would agree with that on
some level anyways well it has been I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about while it has become fashionable to
point to Amazon as a villain in this
story to the extent that there should be
blame at all that blame should rest with
the crafters of the tax code Congress
well then you got to keep going how did
they get put in that position huh
also if you're Amazon you have billions
of dollars you can you can with
lobbyists you can force the
[ __ ] people into doing what you want
to do so it makes them look like they
did it and then also you do have unions
which had to be created because there
was slave labor and child labor in this
[ __ ] country and then eventually they
were [ __ ] [ __ ] and leaning on
shovels and then they became what the
[ __ ] they were fighting and then the
[ __ ] factories are like well I will
go [ __ ] yourself have fun with you Union
we're leaving isn't that what happened
so now we got to bribe him to come back
our [ __ ] politicians are underpaid so
then they got to grab their ankles and
make [ __ ] laws like this just so
these [ __ ] American country don't
want to pay taxes we'll come back here
and do business I see I want to see one
of you guys do that without reading oh
wait you do it to pay them more no he
gave me a link all of it is here all
right no left then I'll have to read
that if I can find a [ __ ] moment in
my house what I'm not getting kicked out
all right pay them more dear Billy pay
greedy politicians more bur now go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] yourself you don't even
know what politicians make I'd like the
local level like your town
representative the guy makes like twelve
fifteen hundred bucks a [ __ ] year two
grand a year so you can yell at him
about every crack and the [ __ ]
sidewalk every time he goes down the
street and tries to get himself a
[ __ ] egg over easy at the local diner
big fan of the podcast but I hate when
you constantly say we should pay
politicians more looking at statistics
politicians make more than the average
American at what level the whole point
of a politician is to serve the
community oh my god don't give me this
Boy Scout [ __ ] and its people so why
would giving politicians more money make
them do the right thing when right now
they're making more than most Americans
and still screwing us over us over and
working with big corporations well this
is why
okay they should they should have [ __ ]
you money because the amount of money
that it costs us that they're so
brutally underpaid you should not only
make half a million dollars a year to be
President of the United States with all
of those stresses and you have to make
decisions and drop [ __ ] bombs that
are gonna land not just on bad guys but
also on babies and you're gonna age in
[ __ ] dog years all right your whole
past is gonna be dragged out they're
gonna make fun of your children they're
gonna talk about every broad that you
have a [ __ ] bang door anything that
you ever did the half of the country no
matter what the [ __ ] you do is gonna say
you're the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
and try to take away the job the entire
time you're in there and you make less
money than a [ __ ] YouTube star all
right my point is is that if you
actually gave them [ __ ] you money I
don't know it is human greed though I
would think that they would be less
susceptible to being bribed by these
[ __ ] corporations into doing exactly
what the [ __ ] they want which is what
they've done how they let people in the
food industry get on the Food and Drug
Committee so they've turned our [ __ ]
food supply into poison now why are you
guys making me talk about this [ __ ] I
want to get into this anyways the
average income is around thirty two
thousand two forty six thousand dollars
a year well that's way more than a town
selectman which is far lower than what a
politicians make now what it as a
senator as the president yeah that is
far lower also take into consideration
that this let's also like say what the
[ __ ] are those other people doing for a
job these people are running the country
you don't think that that deserves a
wage which is far lower than what
politicians make see this is what look
at them
you're gonna crunch the numbers the
other we also take into consideration
that the average includes the
one-percent billionaires and
millionaires that throw the statistics
way off without okay well then if you're
gonna do that then you have to throw out
senators and the president's income and
then what is it so you're gonna sit
there and you're gonna take away the top
one percent the highest you're gonna
grade your end on a curve and you're not
going to grade my end on a
see once again this is why you shouldn't
listen to this person or or me members
of the Congress of Congress earned a
base salary $174,000 a year most are
higher than that alright that's pretty
vague governors are paid between 70,000
and more than a hundred ninety thousand
state legislature an average of eighty
one thousand seventy nine court level
politicians averaged close to two
hundred thousand local elected officials
can make up to 200 grand depending on
the city side yeah I think they're all
grossly underpaid considering what
they're doing running the country
why is running the country do you make
less money than four jerk-offs that care
that created an app how come they make
less than that like you're belittling
what it is they do for a job
they're out there they're supposed to be
fighting for us and they get paid
peanuts and all they do is get yelled at
the whole [ __ ] time they get blamed
for everything I mean you you don't you
have a problem with you don't have a
problem with those numbers okay but you
don't have a problem with [ __ ] like
athletes making the [ __ ] money
they're making how come they make how
come I'm gonna [ __ ] a guy who stops a
baseball makes in one [ __ ] year makes
more goddamn money than a [ __ ] a
president makes their entire eight years
in office you'll never convince me you
will never convince me because this is
the thing all those [ __ ] [ __ ] put
up with being yelled at put up with all
of the [ __ ] so that eventually they
can get the brass ring of being
president and then they can go on the
speech tour and make 300 grand a night
to those exact same [ __ ] corrupt
[ __ ] that put them in office Jesus
Christ why am i this is supposed to be a
light Paul up podcast why am i why am I
talking about this I I disagree with
everything that you're [ __ ] saying I
think it's I think your argument is weak
the fact that you had to throw out the
billionaire's at the top
I just I don't think that that's like I
don't think that that's a fair [ __ ]
argument
I don't wait a minute hey wait was that
actually an in favor of my argument now
mal could [ __ ] confused here which is
another reason why you shouldn't listen
to this oh no that wasn't in defense of
his argument so if you throw out that
will adjust it down even more dude I I
think that I think that what you're
saying here okay is is what everybody
does is they take the numbers and they
adjust them in a [ __ ] way that
supports the goddamn argument okay you
will never convince me that the
President of the United States making
less money a year then a [ __ ] YouTube
star makes in two or three months is not
being grossly underpaid considering that
you got one guy who - who's running this
[ __ ] who thinks that [ __ ] global
warming is is a hoax like that's the
level of power the guy that he can pull
us out of the [ __ ] the the Paris
agreement like that I can just you can
get some some [ __ ] reality TV show
star guy can get that [ __ ] thing to
make 500 grand yeah I don't know I don't
know I think the jobs a little more
important than that the [ __ ]
Commissioner of football makes thirty
million dollars a [ __ ] year Roger
Goodell makes thirty million dollars a
[ __ ] year he makes sixty times what
the President of the United States makes
to run a football league you don't think
that that's grossly underpaid if you
don't think that hey you know what I
agree with you you're right you're
absolutely right the [ __ ] do I care who
gives a [ __ ]
it's not gonna change anything all right
retirement hey Bill hey Bill retiring at
70 per-- huge fans setting love to you
and that you and the lovely family from
New York
all right I'm guessing that now he's
gonna [ __ ] all over my plant my
girlfriend 22 and I 20 are planning to
move to northern Portugal to live off
the land in the mountainous woodsy
region why Portugal you may ask
I didn't ask well I am first generation
American my parents move
here together in their mid-20s my
grandparents who now live with us in the
US due to age are allowing my girlfriend
and I to move there to live in their
home as our own apart from the main
house on the property there is a smaller
one that is unfurnished we have chosen
to reside in the smaller four when the
time comes as my parents are likely to
retire and move back into the main house
in these next few years until then we
are saving every penny of ours me by
delivering pizza and her by being a
manager at a trampoline park with this
money we plan to fully renovate that
smaller house our goal is essentially be
off the grid we want to have solar for
energy wood furnace for heat chickens
sheep fruits and veggies etc we will
need a tractor to maintain land for
agriculture carrying firewood from
separate plots of land a mountainous
woods that we are also fortunate to be
allowed to use the government offers an
incentive subsidies to individuals who
have animals such as goats and sheep
because they eat the underbrush in the
forest preventing forest fires they also
offer subsidies of things like diesel
for people who own tractors and
cultivate land this is a long email we
mapped out how much we make and our goal
over the next few years is to have at
least the very least 55 grand most of
that will be going towards renovating
the house and the cost of getting set up
our goal is to not have any payments or
outgoing money after the initial setup
apart from personal pleasures /
necessities coffee deodorant and
occasional soccer match etc water comes
from the mountains the town has its own
Wi-Fi which is surprisingly pretty good
for the location in the mountains food
will be all homegrown and Portugal has
universal health care now of course we
are also planning on having an income
although not a large one yeah because
I'm wondering how eventually you're
gonna run out of deodorant money aren't
you as I mentioned over over his years
my grandfather purchased plots of lands
some in the mountains and some
flat plash pasture types made for
harvesting grapes for wine one of
Portugal's largest exports The Woodlands
offer many trees that can be chopped and
sold to companies for lumber which we
plan to replant and do over and over
again another way of income which is if
I am being honest will be an
afterthought at least until being
comfortably established largely because
it is something I would have to learn
how to do properly from other family
members that to do it as well there is
planting grapes to sell to wine
companies on the grape plot Lance for so
long I felt no made of motivation to go
to school to get a job working for
someone else that I truly would not
enjoy now I know some people just called
that lazy and I find this interesting
now this is obviously an overview and
condensed to hopefully keep Billy I've
got a kid now burs attention I joke love
to you and your family thank you for all
the laughs you have given us be well
well good luck on that sir you know that
sounds like you're gonna work harder
than you would ever have to work if you
stayed in society man but I think that's
cool that could be a great I can't say
simple life that's a difficult life but
a rewarding one and you just kind of
chill but I can't really chill you got a
[ __ ] bust your ass every day but you
know eventually you build up you know
the trees and the grapes and shed you
got yourself your own little business I
think that's great if what I heard
Portugal is absolutely gorgeous so uh in
the Pyrenees that's the only thing I
know about that the Pyrenees separates
southern France for ma no wait no no
that's Spain in France you guys a lot
you guys a landlocked with Spain there
right well that's great good luck to you
you told me not to buy anything and I
didn't write dear professor Perot my
name is Gabriel or Gabriel I am 33 years
old from Puerto Rico and I'm currently
living in Maryland I became an instant
fan the first time I saw you a bit about
how we are the only species that tries
to save its sick or injured populations
the that's why there is no traffic on
the Serengeti was just brilliant
I was at a rock show the other night to
see a band I have been following for
about 15 years now after taking a break
from all the crowd surfing in moss pit
chaos I found myself in line to buy some
March as I looked at what was available
nothing jumped out at me but being
sentimental and all nevertheless I tried
to see what I could purchase that would
not make me feel like I had just gotten
ripped off after I got home and the
adrenaline and worn off as they handed
my credit card to the store attendant
with an autograph tour poster in hand I
recalled the advice you would give your
younger self in a modest New York
apartment why was I about to drop an
extravagant amount of money on a printed
piece of cardboard you asked me I
actually I didn't I said Bill I guess I
just want this moment to last forever I
put the poster down asked for my car
back and quickly went back to the mosh
pit where I had met a guy who would
ensure I was always able to crowd surf
when I wanted after the show I told the
guy thanks and that it was a pleasure
being his rock show buddy
we fist bumped hugged it out and then
when our lie then went about our lives
most likely never to see each other
again
now my way to the car I realized that I
was trying to buy salvation through that
poster I could hang it up on the [ __ ]
wall and look at it from my [ __ ]
couch as proof that I did seize the day
and live life to its fullest and I
laughed at the irony of that scene
feeling good about myself that I tried
to live my life to the fullest while
staring at a [ __ ] piece of paper on a
couch I am lucky I was able to put that
piece of overpriced cardboard down and
go back to sweating it out on the show
floor with everyone else if I had gotten
the poster I would have had tried to
protect it I would have start stared at
the rest of the show from afar I would
have lived life from a distance as a
[ __ ] observer this guy's going deep
or this lady you told me not to buy
anything and in the process made me
realize that all things come to an end
it's inevitable we therefore take
snapshots of life to hang on the wall in
an attempt to make the moment last
forever god damn this is [ __ ] deep
but in the process we're
[ __ ] missing the moment itself I
don't want to be the person holding the
camera I had to choose pictures or
memories poster a rock show buddy be in
the moment or hang it up on the wall
well there you go there's some [ __ ]
war after all my [ __ ] a libertarian
horseshit that you had to sit through
which I do apologize for cuz I really
haven't paid attention anything in a lot
of tip long time I just got fed up I was
just mad as hell and I wasn't gonna take
it anymore um alright did anybody see
the Flyers capitols game let's talk a
little bread and circus here what a
[ __ ] great game that was and the
Flyers are scoring goals by the bunches
and I'll tell you it's not happy about
that the Rose Bowl tailgate legend
himself Joe Bartnik the [ __ ] arguably
the number one Pittsburgh Penguins fan
in the United States of America he's not
happy about that I'll tell you I've been
watching the Flyers I've been checking
out the st. Louis Blues st. Louis Blues
doing the exact same thing they did last
year playing the trap defense to a
[ __ ] that to an art form boring ass
[ __ ] games I will tell you that dump
and chase dump and chase with the Blues
but I still think the Blues are gonna be
the team to beat I also started to watch
a good game with the ABS and the Ducks
last night and I watched the replay of
the Bruins they beat Tampa Bay but
Stamkos is out for the next four to six
weeks so you know we weren't beating
their best we shall see but I think that
I think the st. Louis Blues are still
the team to beat and I think if we faced
him in the finals we would still and it
is the finals right no it's the final
Stanley Cup final the NBA Finals the
Stanley Cup final I think we would run
into the same problem again which was
last year which is you have to beat
those guys in four to five games or they
are going to beat you down to the talent
level of their team that's it I have the
next few days off I am NOT going to do
[ __ ] I put on a little bit of weight
going to the Lakers game and
you know [ __ ] idiot basically since
the beginning of November so I got about
five seven pounds I got a drop here and
it starts today actually it started
yesterday but I got on the scale for the
first time in a while cuz I knew I
wasn't gonna like the answer and finally
I just woke up this morning it's like
Bill the answer still exists you just
don't know what it is so why don't you
[ __ ] scratch the itch and step on
that thing so I got to get myself back
down to a buck 72 that's why I need to
bake I'm still in the 170s 179 by my
fingertips so I'll take that off for the
next couple of weeks just try to be a
good little boy all right watch the
MotoGP this Sunday don't listen to me
when it comes to politics I don't know
pay the politicians less photo over the
[ __ ] you won't just watch Fox News all
day watch CNN just have a good time
don't listen to me all right go [ __ ]
yourself have a great weekend hey what's
going on it's Bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday March
5th 2012 and how you doing
what's going on I am officially on
vacation everybody I take my special
Saturday night everything went great and
I want to thank everyone who came out to
the Lincoln on Saturday night I had an
awesome time and I think I got another
good one so before I kissed that our
goodbyes and have to write a new one
I'm gonna chill here for the next four
days I got four days off before I do
some other [ __ ] but it's not uh it's
not stand-up related but I want to thank
everyone who came out to the shows once
again there's always obviously special
nights and everybody came down everybody
was ready to laugh and and it went you
know went pretty I think went pretty
good we shall see we shall see and
that's it so I don't know what to do
with myself I have four days what I
don't have to do [ __ ] I'm gonna play
some drums I'm gonna play some guitar
I'm gonna drive my truck that I haven't
driven in like three weeks
but I've been on the road every single
week and uh I come back and I haven't
even had time because I come back and I
got a deal with all my all the mail
that's piled up so I just go in and I
start it up in the garage and I backed
it into so just you know committing
suicide or is he just making sure it's
still uh you know I don't even know why
I just feel like you have to start it up
every couple of days so when I'm done
with my podcast today I am gonna be
driving that thing with my arm out the
window it's a beautiful sunny California
day like friggin 80 degrees out here
global warming the Golden Age you guys
realize we're living in the Golden Age
of global warming right now like the
beginning parts of global warming
there's going to be a lot of you know I
you know do it you know I like the
weather and then eventually it's gonna
be like why my socks wet
[Music]
so anyways yes I am on vacation I've
taped another hour it is behind me um
there's a lot of things I'm gonna miss
but I miss a lot of that hour but I feel
like this is like a transitional special
for me I really do we're just as far as
you know stuff I'm trying to achieve you
know it's just trying to get better as a
comedian there's a few things on this
special that I haven't had the balls to
try another one so you know this one is
this one's a little bit differently so
hopefully some of the skills I'm trying
to learn and this one will I'll have
down pat for the next one and add to my
arsenal my ass and all and that's it
that's it I worked with seat and Smith
opened up for me anybody who's wondering
I ended up you know I worked at them
like four or five years ago at the DC
improv and then last year when I was on
Jim Norton's tour GME know and when I
was on his tour the anti-social tour
that
that's right it was me him Brewer and
Dave Attell and we came down to DC and
we had ran into Seaton again it opened
up for us and he had grown by leaps and
bounds and he was awesome so it was a no
brainer came back to DC and he knocked
it out of the park again and on a
sidetrack - Jim Norton's toward the anti
social network tor is back out as far as
I know with a new killer lineup him Dave
Attell and then they added Artie Lange
and Doug Stanhope and Doug Stanhope has
a new CD out I believe I just heard
about it the other day because he's got
such a great name it's it's called
before turning the gun on himself and I
heard the cover is just like a
microphone and a blood spattered wall I
don't know I think he I think he's
[ __ ] awesome so anyways so even though
I'm not sitting here in a row Robin
Williams Hawaiian shirt right now that's
mentally where I'm at I'm psyched I
somehow pulled it off again fold them
again special went great and I should be
getting a rough cut of it coming up and
I think it'll be out by like October and
hopefully you guys will buy it
you know III twittered something because
I don't like saying tweeting I tweeted
something how I finally got a copy of
that a DVD copy of Black Sabbath live in
Paris 1970 and I'm sitting there
watching it on the road and just [ __ ]
Ozzy's one all right you know just one
of the greatest frontman of all time
it's Black Sabbath in their their
absolute prime it's just such a no
[ __ ] show it's just for guys on
stage just blowin the crowds heads back
it's just they're just [ __ ]
unbelievable
it's just so [ __ ] raw and you know
just I honestly it's the way it should
be done I think anybody who's ever gonna
play in a band should watch this [ __ ]
concert so anyway so I'm talking I
tweeted that I Twitter that I got the
[ __ ] thing and I got like three
people going oh I got it too
and then they show links to it on
YouTube as if I didn't know it was on
YouTube you know I got [ __ ] you fool and
then they would show it to me they're
right it's [ __ ] ridiculous
if something's that great you should pay
for it I think you know I don't know if
I'm coming off as like a [ __ ] old man
here but if you if you're gonna do [ __ ]
like that
you can't [ __ ] about music today and be
like what happened to music it's like
well that's what happened to music it
all became free the whole industry
collapse granted it was a piece of [ __ ]
industry that was [ __ ] people over
but it could guide you to some pretty
amazing artists as much as there's
always been the Justin Bieber's because
there has been okay you know like I've
always said when the when the Beatles
will make it album so was Herman in the
hermit's okay so when they were making
Rubber Soul Herman and the hermit's were
in the [ __ ] studio down the hall
going I'm Henry you might to write a
song that [ __ ] stupid and you can't
even you you get to the second verse you
can't even come up with more lyrics and
then you somehow get away with they got
away with it god bless them alright so
nothing has happened to music what's
happened is the music industry has
changed so I think that that's why it's
made it it's weird like there's more
opportunity but there's there's less I
don't know there's less like I don't
know how like a Pink Floyd would do it
nowadays or something like that at some
point you need some giant machine to let
everybody know that you're out there
right I don't know maybe you don't I
don't [ __ ] know but I like owning the
DVD so stuff stuff that I really like I
go out and buy the DVD I look at it it's
like having the gold behind you money
you know because just like the dollar my
computer can crash my ipod can crash
alright and then I just got this
worthless [ __ ] thing but if I got the
DVD I can just go out and get some more
currency
and have that thing backing it up does
that make sense well if it doesn't go
read the case against the Fed it's a
wonderful read so anyways I was coming
back from DC and I'm in the airport and
this guy just had this classic [ __ ]
hat it was first of all the hat was like
it was a baseball cap but the the the
visor and the the front part we'd have
the sports logo or whatever it says that
was all leather and the guy was wearing
cowboy boots nice jeans a really nice
dress shirt and a really nice sport coat
and then he had this hat on over his Tom
Landry haircut which I'm rapidly
approaching our airline I should say and
it said on the Hat it said God guns and
guts made America let's keep all three
you know do you think that's right do
you think God guns and guts did it I
mean there's a lot of stuff that you can
you because you can take that a bunch of
different ways because you know depends
on all how you define those three things
that's what I loved about that hat
because that hat could be a liberal hat
or extremely right-wing depending on how
you read it you know take it at face
value it's extremely right-wing you know
our morals or or the Second Amendment
and then having the courage being a
stand-up guy you know get out there you
do you do what's right right that thing
or you could go the the complete
opposite way where the dysfunctional way
people use religion guns would take care
of the slavery and genocide and and guts
would be all the all the gore that it
took
I'm not trashing this country this
country came about the way anything else
came about every that's how all all
societies come about somebody gets
squashed
and then the people who win rewrite it
they put some nice music behind it right
and they you know they tell some truths
and they kind of smooth over some other
[ __ ] but I got this what I love about
that hat you know I always wish that I
had some sort of black belt in martial
arts but I've always been too lazy you
know I'd like to have a gun but I'm
afraid of him you know
but I still walk around night a lot so I
think if I had a hat like that know who
would [ __ ] with you there's no way you
don't think that that person strapped
you know we were going through the
airport security and I was like this
guy's at least gotta have a knife in his
boot like why would you go that far to
have a hat like that I don't know maybe
he just came to some meeting from the
gun lobby I have no idea that's one of
the things I'm doing this month though
I've met a couple of people and I'm
gonna learn how to handle a gun and you
know be comfortable around them and then
decide afterwards if I want to get one
you know as opposed to just be like I'm
scared of those things I don't know why
we have I mean I know I'm one of those
people like I'm terrified of him I
didn't grow up around him and they freak
me out but I totally get him I totally
understand him and I see certain stories
on the news and I think well if somebody
had a gun in the house that probably
that could have gone the other way you
know I don't know you might think I'm a
[ __ ] lunatic but uh just sort of
tapped out of that didn't I you know I
think it's a good time now to read a
little bit advertising what do you guys
think huh I don't care what you think
I'm on vacation I'm gonna hear please
you I just you just called me into the
office this week you know cuz you
couldn't figure out how to put how to
put paper in the copier now all of a
sudden I'm standing here my [ __ ] what
the hell is it where the hell is this
stamps calm let's get on with this here
stamps calm everybody
anyways are you like me everybody do you
hate everything no do you hate going to
the post office right you know when can
you go into the post office and there's
not a line wrapped around the building
like they're selling tickets to a Bon
Jovi concert in the Meadowlands right
you know and you go in there and it's
such a long line that you got to figure
out what supplies you need then you got
to carry them under your arm and
literally be putting the box together as
though as the thing you know the line
moves forward and you're sliding it up
along that long table and then you got
the wrong sized box or you got the wrong
you know envelope oh that you wanted
Express you have a priority envelope you
know go back over there fix it then you
can come right back up to the window and
endure the hateful stares of the hundred
people who weren't here to see me tell
you that it's okay to come back do you
want to go through all of that would it
be great if you could just handle it
yourself in the privacy of your own home
have you ever wanted to do your mail
late at night standing in your underwear
while eating a pop-tart
well with stamps calm you can do it yep
your time is valuable it's important to
use every month a minute wisely so why
waste your time going to the post office
find parking then waiting in line when
you don't have to didn't I just say that
I think I did I don't need to read the
copy I so believe in this product I can
come from my stamps calm I love it I
actually I actually use this [ __ ] man
yeah I should go back to the coffee you
can buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and your printer
you can also you know print posters for
boxes they give you these little scale
which I love because I send out my DVDs
to my gigs this way now just way the
little box you know got my little mr.
McFeely visor on put that stamp on you
know toss that sucker in the mail and
I'm done I show up and it's magically
there I never had to stand in a line I
could be there on my underwear listening
to a CD I can be screaming you know any
word I want at the top of my lungs
trying to keep it clean trying to keep
it clean here folks all right and I know
what you thinking because you just like
anybody else you like you know what Bill
that's all well and good having a post
office in my house with a little bit a
little scale what's in it for me I'll
tell you what it's in for you we got a
special offer right now Stan's calm for
my listeners and my listeners only
unless they're doing this with a bunch
of other podcast I have no idea there's
a no risk trial plus a hundred and ten
dollar bonus offer includes a digital
scale and fifty-five dollars worth of
postage okay but only if you go on and
you use my last name ber what you want
to do is go to stamps comm click on the
radio microphone on the top of the
homepage and type in BER capital B you
are our that stamps.com enter burke at
fifty five dollars in free postage and
you get a scale alright what else what
else could you possibly want everybody
um
so anywho oh speaking of music
what's-his-face Davy Jones died this
week and I can't even tell you how much
that bummed me out I absolutely loved
the Monkees when I was growing up I
loved their music
I loved the comedy I loved the nod to
the Marx Brothers
I loved the nod to the Beatles I loved
that they were a pop band I love that
Mike Nesmith hated being in it and when
he would when they were pretending to
play to a track he'd have his tie going
through the guitar strings as some sort
of silent protest I liked all of it and
I thought they had good music for what
it was I really liked it and I got to
tell you for you youngsters out there
there's nothing worse than when someone
like Davy Jones dies of basically
natural causes because it really just
lets you know how [ __ ] old you are
it's like that guy was 66 Jesus he died
of a heart how the [ __ ] did that guy die
of a heart attack and I'm thinking when
I was when I was watching those first
started watching those shows that guy
was like oh my god I think I started
watching a 73 or 74 so the reruns on
WSBK TV channel 56 in Boston or was it
TV 38 one of the other I used to watch
him and he was probably 25 years old you
know I remember being excited when I saw
him do a guest star in the Brady Bunch
when he took Marcia to the prom I
thought Micky Dolenz was [ __ ]
hilarious and I hate him when he grew
his hair out it thought it looked better
when it was straight like that's how
much of a fan I was by that show and it
just sucks man the [ __ ] that's what
happens to me I'm 44 this year 22 years
so now I could be walking around with my
torso stuffed into a button-down shirt
and all of a sudden collapsed all over
like a tray of macaroni
jesusí right here is is there any reason
to take [ __ ] from anybody if it goes by
that fast other than cops cuz they can
legally kick the [ __ ] of you let's get
to the complaints this week everybody
some lady just absolutely lost her mind
hates my guts now and won't listen to
this podcast anymore and I'd apologize
to her but she says she's not listening
anymore there's no way that she's
listening despite that she wrote like a
five-page email that I'm now gonna read
she has a huge problem with me everybody
so settle it want me to wait you want to
go down to the break room go get
yourself a little coffee cake oh I can
wait I'm on vacation I got nothing
better to do good I'll wait
[Music]
[ __ ] dogs been farting all day today
I don't know what's dealers and it keeps
looking at me like dude you gotta help
me out and I keep going to take it
outside and it just sniffs the grass and
then I bring it back in it starts
farting again and it keeps looking at me
like dude I'm really trying not to [ __ ]
on your rug like I mean that's how I'm
reading her face I think that's what
she's saying I have no idea so anyways
so anyways there we go
subject your podcast is hate speech Oh
geesh bill you probably won't read this
or if you do you will just dismiss me as
a stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] but no matter state
right there she's already draped herself
in the ombre and I'm gonna plow ahead
flag your podcast as of lace has morphed
into hate speech you used to be funny
and I could brush off your hateful
comments with the cringe and a shrug now
wait a minute if it would if they were
hateful write along why would you add
that okay let's just plow him but now
you've gone too far for me to feature a
segment on your podcast devoted to the
deplorable behavior of women is
intolerable for those of you new to my
podcast I've been doing this segment
which i think is hilarious
and needs to be done just to get you
caught up before this lady gives me both
barrels he'll because believe me she
does you know there's a bunch of there's
a bunch of shows out there that that
shine a light on men who beat their
women those pieces of [ __ ] right trying
to stop them from that
behavior there's a bunch of shows out
there that will talk about how who are
these guys you know to say what a woman
could do with their body they'll talk
about the glass ceiling the old boys
network and all that type of stuff when
they shine a light on all of that okay
which they should because that is guys
doing things that they should not be
doing that is not fair to women okay but
mutton so my problem is not that they do
that my problem is that they never shine
a light on [ __ ] that that women do that
is not fair to men so recently if I can
rape my drape myself in some sort of
brave flag I've been reading these
stories about guys who are married their
wife goes out cheats on them has
unprotected sex has a kid with another
[ __ ] guy doesn't tell their husband
and that by the time he figures it out
he has to pay child support for a kid
that isn't even his and it's totally
legal and then I had the audacity to say
that a woman who would do that to her
husband is a [ __ ] evidently that's
hateful speech towards all women
according to this person all right
because she continues and oh does she
ever continue to feature segment on your
podcast devoted to the deplorable
behavior of women is intolerable how is
that any different than someone spending
20 minutes a week on a different podcast
featuring the deplorable behavior
behavior of black people why do they
always go to black people that's always
a that's just like calling me the n-word
this is no difference than slavery
that's people and other groups always do
that always do that all right give me a
goddamn break all right
that she goes women are I mean how is
that a different I'm how is how is what
I'm doing any different by featuring a
segment of women who are doing something
absolutely reprehensible to men how is
that any different than a show that
focuses on men doing anything
reprehensible to women when they show
wifebeaters
I don't look at that like oh my god
they're saying I'm doing it too I think
you
something I really think you're being
really selfish here and the fact that
you could sit here and listen to my
podcast for this long as I've gone off
on fat people I mean Jesus Christ once
talked about hate speech how much [ __ ]
have I talked about Peyton Manning
despite the fact I can't even throw a
football you know if he sent me an email
I would understand I bet it wouldn't
even be as crazy as this she says women
are treated like second-class citizens
all over the world when did I ever say
they weren't and even still in this
country yet you have no problem inciting
further hate and disgust towards your
fellow human beings on this earth how am
i inciting hate when when shosho
wifebeaters is that inciting hatred
towards men if you look at those shows
and that makes you hate all men then
you're a [ __ ]
so basically what you're saying is that
I'm a [ __ ] and that all my listeners
are morons that if I call a woman who
cheats on her husband has a baby with
another guy and makes her husband pay
for that if I call her a [ __ ] that means
I'm calling all women [ __ ] you know is
that what you're saying are you saying
we're all that stupid she said right now
there are men and that is written in
capital letters Amy and men in this
country still capital STI ll discussing
whether or not women should have the
right to contraception and abortion so
yeah I understand that those people
freak me out those people freak me out
and I am a guy and I've never said that
a woman shouldn't have a right to that
so I don't know what you're talking
about this has nothing to do I'm talking
about these [ __ ] [ __ ] that cheat on
their husbands ma'am you know what I
love about all this how come you don't
address what I talked about how come I
can't hear what what do you think about
a woman who would do something like that
I saw it stat the other day that said
13% of kids in this country are not with
their biological father meaning that not
just like you know but that their wife
got like divorced and in and then
remarried and they mean like there's a
guy either knows or doesn't know like
the woman had a kid with somebody else
while they were married like 13% of kids
I mean that means 80% of women on the
up-and-up all right god bless them there
angels but that 13% needs to be taken to
task I mean I would I mean how many guys
are beaten women I would guess they'd
probably be right around that same you
know maybe a little higher I have no
idea
let's just let's say it's 20 plus say 20
percent of guys beat their women should
they not be called out and be called
cowardly pieces of [ __ ] you know and if
you call them cowardly piece of [ __ ]
what I have a right to sit there and
look at that and be like well that's now
you're you're inciting further hate and
disgust toward all men you're being
really selfish here man because I go off
on everybody this podcast is over the
top and it's crazy I call guys [ __ ] on
this podcast and you're being really
selfish right now and now you know you
make this big long speech and then
you're gonna take your ball and go home
I look look at this look at all she's
bringing up here women are still earned
only 70 cents for every dollar a man
earns I think you guys should make the
same amount but I also don't think that
that that number is accurate $77.77 for
every dollar than a man earns because if
you include divorce settlements you get
to keep your 77 cents plus his 50% his
50 cents so then he's down to 50 and
then you're up to a dollar 37 [ __ ]
yourself you oversensitive jackass
good lord go buy a bigger bra I don't
know what your [ __ ] problem is I hope
that bugged you to that I said that that
was deliberately supposed to be
offensive all right so go [ __ ] write
a letter to [ __ ] [ __ ] hair calm
because I don't give a [ __ ] all right
in short we are still not equal to our
male counterparts and we will forever be
labeled the weaker sex well with that
attitude of course you will you know I
don't think you're the weaker sex I
think that that's all a myth I think
that that actually makes you stronger
you know because guys are [ __ ] idiots
and they think cuz they can do more
push-ups than their woman that they're
actually you know that makes them
smarter you know I don't know my [ __ ]
door bells ringing are you serious hang
on a second I gotta go up here and then
I get a
read the rest of this hold on alright so
I'm back little winded but I'm back I'm
back
so anyways bla bla bla bla bla it just
keeps going on and on and on and on um
where the hell is it where the hell was
I weaker sex and then she tries to break
me down psychologically but my mom not
hugging me if that's the case then I'm
sorry for you I hate when people do that
it's like you're not sorry for me you
hate me right now okay so stop acting
like you're really sorry for me and
you're showing some sort of empathy
you're not showing empathy you're being
really selfish like I said I go off on
everything here I've never said that a
woman should make the same amount an
hour as a guy I never should said that a
guy should be able to hit a woman I've
never said that what the thing I'm
trying to shine a light too is that some
of these divorce settlements are
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
and and that when a woman cheats on a
guy and has a kid with another person
and then the poor sap who married her
has to pay for that you don't think
that's [ __ ] up Howard Stern just did a
great story on it uh last week somebody
sent me an email he did a story about a
guy who was in that situation and he
refused to play pay the child support
and they said we're gonna send you to
jail he's gonna go to jail cuz his wife
cheated on him had unprotected sex a to
hell with aids let's roll the dice with
my husband's life right has unprotected
sex has a kid he doesn't realize it
figures it's his cuz it's his wife's
pregnant why would he think that it's
somebody else's he starts making the
payments next thing you know you know
he's such reason the kid figures out
it's not his kid and as a natural
reaction I don't want to pay for that
and they're like the law is just like no
you have to pay for it let me ask you
this ma'am do you have any empathy for
that you seem to have all this empathy
for women and women's issues and like
somehow I'm supposed to still respect
you despite the fact that you could give
a [ __ ] if this injustice is done on the
other side it doesn't make any sense and
I want to see like this is like focusing
on this issue this is an issue for some
reason that is just not talked about
whatsoever it's just sort of accepted
and I think it's an absolute I think
it's absolutely deplorable I think it's
deplorable so I have the right to talk
about it you know what I mean and if you
want to get offended and you want to be
selfish and just be like well that isn't
fair what if I had a whole segment every
week and all I did was talk about
wifebeaters you know what you'd probably
send me an email I just want you to tell
you I love your podcast even more it is
just it's you are just you are a hero to
hear a man out there just just letting
these these these cowardly pieces of
[ __ ] know that it's you be [ __ ] but
now all of a sudden I'm talking about
women who are doing [ __ ] that you're not
even doing at what point in any of these
stupid [ __ ] rants that I've done have
I ever said that all women are doing
this I never have I never said that all
women cheat on their husbands and have a
kid out of wedlock
I didn't alright do I make
generalizations
abso-fucking-lutely it's a comedy I
paint with a broad brush I'm [ __ ]
around okay jesus [ __ ] christ stop
being so goddamn selfish okay and if you
don't want to listen to my podcast don't
listen to my podcast anymore and other
than that you know I mean go [ __ ]
yourself i I don't I don't I don't know
this is what she's doing is is a is a
pet peeve that I have like that happens
to me like sometimes when I do shows and
at the end of my shows someone will come
up to me and just be like look you know
I have a good sense of humor but but
subject whatever my [ __ ] phone
they'll just be like you know what
that's never funny that is never all the
lovely Nia everybody hang on one second
hang on one second hello hey I'm taping
my podcast right now is this urgent are
you on the side of the road
we got triple-a no no I
the dog was farting and I thought I'd
had to [ __ ] in the house so I took it
outside and then it just sniffed around
and peed yeah I was a pain in the ass so
I'm gonna get back to the podcast all
right all right that's all you in like a
half all right
anyways oh and then she goes on to say
that the terms I use will then cause you
know people to use so you know let's I
[ __ ] around and use these terms she then
thinks that people are gonna use them
seriously you don't Ameen and I'm sure
if you will but that's not on me
somebody who does that it's cuz you're a
[ __ ]
and I like it's not my responsibility to
[ __ ] babysit anybody
once they're an adult if you don't know
not to call women these terms okay
although I will tell you this if you
know there is a time to call a woman a
[ __ ] okay and that's when you find out
that your son is not your son and you
still have to pay for there's a reason
that that word doesn't does exist
all right all right there sweetheart so
I hope you come back to the podcast I
hope that you actually listen and we'll
respond and I don't hear another [ __ ]
word out of you unless you tell me what
you think about those kinds of [ __ ]
women who'd do that okay and stop
bringing up slavery and all this other
[ __ ] and try to drag all this other crap
into it alright you stay in your own
goddamn lane sweetheart
alright good lord to compare yourself
not being able to vote to being enslaved
really that's another one that gets so
that's a whole nother [ __ ] topic every
[ __ ] person out there just tries to
[ __ ] jump on that you know that's our
n-word go [ __ ] yourself
anyways I can't believe you just did
that why did you flick that BIC right in
my face you burned off two eyebrow hairs
that's my Dresden wedding fashion advice
see I love this these advice now that
here we go wedding fashion advice bill I
am getting married in June oh isn't that
romantic a June wedding and refused to
wear a tux i'ma tell you something right
now sir you're gonna have a happy
marriage you're gonna have to have a
happy marriage good for the fact that
you still have a backbone
and you refused to wear a tux and though
the woman that you're gonna marry this
angel is fine with it
that's the you got a winner right there
all right that's perfect it's gonna be a
good little give-and-take little surf
and turf and then all you got to do was
just admit when you're wrong in the
relationship it gives you [ __ ]
credibility so when you actually [ __ ]
that you they'll they'll think he
actually he actually feels us all right
so simple question simple question bow
tie
or regular tie with my suit I'd like to
do something different but don't want to
come off as a douche um I gotta be
honest I would go with the tie there's
only there's only there's three people
in the world that can get away with a
bow tie all right an economics major and
even then not then you have to be an
economist on TV talking about the GNP
then you can wear a bow tie if you're
one of those if you're a Muslim but
you're a black guy for some reason
they're worse suits and bow ties they
don't seem to go for the the whatever
the [ __ ] you call that thing what do you
call that thing Jesus not gonna be more
offensive I don't what you call it the
thing that you just is it doesn't see
it's sort of the original scrunchie not
scrunchie what the [ __ ] are those things
called it's sort of the original Snuggie
you know except it's just all the way
over you like I don't think Muslims in
the Middle East ever get cold when they
fall asleep on the couch because they
have that they got that whole long thing
over them right oh my god that was
offensive I'm from Syria and I listen to
your podcast I don't care and the third
person is if you make chicken for a lot
of people you could also wear a bow tie
does Colonel Sanders does that guy I
mean speaking of slavery tell me that
guy doesn't look like he at least owns
at least 12 slaves at some point in his
life I don't there's just something
about him was very plantation esque
did he have that that Old South look
about him Oh
I don't know you know some next time Nia
comes on here I'm gonna ask her she has
a theory about you want to talk about
like advertising that type of thing she
is convinced there's a KFC in Koreatown
out here in Los Angeles and she is
convinced that they draw the Colonel
Sanders a little bit differently to make
him almost look like he's racially mixed
like he still looks like Colonel Sanders
you know what I mean but he looks a
little uh I don't know that's what she
says I don't see it you know she thinks
they put a little - a Mongolian in him
[Laughter]
which if they did I think that is
[ __ ] hilarious like I would say that
at that point you had exhausted all ways
of trying to figure out how to sell
chicken at that location you have
definitely hit the wall as far as
profits what the [ __ ] else can we do we
got crispy we got we got the original we
got the the unchristian potpie what do
we do hey what if we made Colonel
Sanders a little uh a little more rough
Colonel Sanders chin ish make him a
little more just a little bit of Asian
in the face you know somewhere you know
maybe the cheekbones are I don't know
what - a Korean in there you know what
I'll take a picture of I'll take a
picture of that one and I'll take a
picture of a regular one and I want to
see if you guys can tell the difference
cause personally I don't see it but it
makes me laugh my every time we drive by
it both me and Nia start cracking up and
she in and she starts presenting her
argument go look at his eyes look at his
eyes and I'm going they look the same
she goes I'm telling you it's different
but the problem is is we've never been
to can't look across the street and see
like just a regular one so I'm gonna do
the wonderful technology of the speaking
of that you know what I got I got the
iPhone 4s I finally gave in to that [ __ ]
I will not be doing any [ __ ] ads for
this goddamn phone this thing Jesus
Christ I might as well have bought a
Fiat
[ __ ] thing is such a pain in the ass
the goddamn home button every couple of
days craps out and then I got to go down
to the thing you don't have one of those
geniuses figure it out
alright and I know what you're gonna say
well do just reset it you just hold down
the power button and that home button
together and wait till the Apple can't I
did that I did it it's not working for
me so now on my vacation I have to go
back over to the [ __ ] ice store and
talk to those people and make an
appointment and have them I don't know
the exact reason why I never got the
phone whose cuz it always crapped out
all right I don't need a phone that can
take amazing pictures an amazing video
but it's I can't use it as a phone it's
just it's a pain in the ass so uh [ __ ]
the iPhone alright did you hear that
ghost of Steve Jobs um alright so
anyways yeah I would go with the tie but
uh but you know if you're gonna if
you're gonna not wear a tux which is
really funny because a tuxedo is really
just some cheap [ __ ] thing that you
get down the street that somebody's worn
to God knows how many different events
what I would do is I would wear I would
get like a suit like you were gonna go
do a talk show like Letterman or
something just get the best suit you
possibly could have some unbelievable
shoes I'd even go with the little the
pocket square cufflinks just look like a
[ __ ] million bucks
yeah but definitely don't do the bowtie
man that's Jesus Christ then you would
look like a douche the only time a guy
can wear a bowtie and not look like a
douche is if he is wearing a tuxedo I
think because then they got like the
colored buff buttons in that little that
little half a man girdle the cumberbund
that they have down there all right bill
flight made simple do you remember you
guys remember a couple weeks ago when I
was talking about how I didn't
understand I just want to stay on our
plane stays off the ground I've had
people try to explain it to me a zillion
different ways you're surfing on the air
the lift the under the wing over the
wing all this [ __ ] this person's going
to try to explain it to me alright bill
in regards to your previous podcast
where you wondered how an airplane flew
and resigned yourself to lifelong
ignorant there are two basic principles
at work here I won't bore you with
jargon or math the plane wings are
shaped so that so that air
pushed downward when it comes in contact
with the bottom of the wing all right I
got to read this over and over again to
get this the plane's wings are shaped so
that air is pushed downward when it
comes in contact with the wing are they
I guess they are well if I've stuck my
hand out the window if I had it if I had
it level if I wanted to push it down
that I would tilt it forward but I think
that it tilted back aren't they oh but
when it goes over it it pushes it down
dude there's no way you're gonna have to
sit here and like you're gonna have to
hold my hand and walk me through you're
gonna have to be in the room there's no
way I'm be able to figure this out all
right the plane's wings are shaped so
that air is pushed downward when it
comes into contact with the bottom of
the wing this produces a force equal to
the one the air was pushed with in the
opposite direction and I'm tapping out I
don't know what that means this produces
a force equal to the one what one to the
one the air was pushed with in the
opposite direction okay secondly top of
the wing is shaped so that the air
flowing over it is going very fast
faster than the air flowing underneath
the wing yeah people have told me this I
don't get it
the faster the air flows the less
pressure it puts on the wing surface
because the air on top is moving faster
the pressure on the bottom is higher
though this is the thing I need to go
all the way back to like basic
principles of physics you know what I
mean this is like I'm trying to teach
you how to play drums and I'm showing
you an intermediate drum fill and you
can't even play a beat yet I had no
scientific background whatsoever so if
you if you can suggest a hey kids
uncle schlubby is gonna teach us about
physics right and there's got a picture
of some guy dressed in a mascot suit I
want to start with a science book uncle
schlubby I'm sorry I couldn't think of
[ __ ] what I'm on vacation funny this
week bill how do I handle the parents of
my kid my son beat up Jesus Christ you
know something I deserve this because I
said stop asking me advice that has to
do with relationships because I was sick
of that [ __ ]
and as much as I'm enjoying
all of these I have to like now make
sure I don't get in trouble legally so
before I answer that speaking of legally
speaking of Legally let's uh let's read
some let's read some the other [ __ ]
advertising for this week without [ __ ]
did I do with it oh there it is
alright spot number two alright alright
so I already showed you how you didn't
have to go to the post office how would
you guys like to have an arcade your own
goddamn home would you would that'd be
great
are you sick of going down to the video
store and sitting there talking to can I
help you can I help you with something
talking to those nerds what do you think
about this one what do you think about
that one
it's all about staying anyhow everybody
getting some powdered food having your
own windmill right putting stamps on
your own envelopes that you printed out
yourself when your computer let's go to
the next level of becoming a complete
hermit gamefly.com everybody it's the
video game rental system that delivers
video games to your door and now PC
games right to your PC
what's wrong with the Mac Gamefly has
over eight thousand titles to choose
from and works with all systems Monday
morning podcast listeners get 15 day a
15 day trial free trial by going to WWE
my comm slash / WWE gamefly.com slash
brr-brr all right and what do you get
you get eight thousand different titles
so I would have to think that that's
basically everything from I'm gonna
shoot you in the face all the way down
to pac-man I mean they got everything
all the classics all the way up to the
top I mean they have to eight thousand
titles to choose from and this is the
thing you me if you don't want to do it
you for 15 days they giving you they
giving you a free trial just like a drug
dealer gives you a couple of free
samples right you hit the needle a
couple times they got you hooked you
know
except rather than ruining your life
you'll still be able to go to you still
be able to go to work and you know what
you're gonna be able to deal with your
boss even better cuz you know the second
he's done running his yep and that
whistle blows and you slide down that
dinosaur into that car you use with your
feet you're going home to 8,000
different games alright 15-day free
trial
gamefly.com slash birth okay that's it
alright back to
Podcast let's see if bill can try not to
get sued here so this guy's write me
this thing he's basically he's dealing
with the parents of the kid his son beat
up let's got to make you feel good that
your kid won as much as you probably
says probably gonna have to do with
something of a lawsuit or something
hi bill I was listening to one of the
earlier podcast about when one of your
listeners has been getting [ __ ] from his
neighbor because of driving too fast and
neighborhood you followed up with a
hilarious dialogue of how we should
handle his neighbor that also brought up
memories of how he thought of it also
brought up memories about how you
thought about talk talking to your
downstairs neighbor was the most
ridiculous move ever so that got me
thinking I have a son in the seventh
grade who just served a suspension last
week for getting into a fight with
another kid you know it's funny that
your son is in the seventh grade cuz
that is right at that tipping point
where fights aren't just you know
headlocks and all of a sudden people are
starting to you know hit puberty all of
a sudden they weigh over a hundred
pounds they're a little more coordinated
they got a hundred one hundred ten
hundred fifteen there's always that one
Bigfoot kid who's like a hundred forty
pounds all of a sudden fight start get
there's like blood and [ __ ] you know so
here we go seventh grade his seventh
grade son just got suspended last week
for getting into a fight with another
kid the fight was apparently over a
dispute during their gym class where the
other kid purposely threw a basketball
at my son's head a few times when he
wasn't looking after repeated hits my
son somehow turned into a maniac caught
the other kid by surprise tripped a kid
on the ground and started wailing on the
kid's face breaking his nose you know
you know what that is that's that
classic kid who's been picked on and all
of a sudden he just [ __ ] spaz his out
probably making those noises punching
him while crying remember that that was
always epic when the weak kid finally
flipped out and beat the other kid down
or at least just got a couple of good
ones in before getting pounded himself
you know good for him that's that's the
rid that's tough
first belt like a lot of those martial
arts class they have the white belt with
what you walk in with which is basically
all you know about fighting is to get
hit a couple times and then making that
noise you flail with both hands and feet
right so anyways after repeated hits my
some out oh whatever were mean some some
of the other kids friends then jumped in
okay
in and fought my son off my son
unfortunately got a black eye from the
friends cheap shot I don't think this is
a bad thing man I mean I think this is
basically I think he did he did right by
himself
he was getting picked on and that all
the other kids are looking at him and if
he doesn't do anything then he's saying
yeah I'm the kid you can throw a
basketball at my head and I won't do
anything about it and then despite the
fact that you kid got a black eye in the
end I mean all those other kids see like
wow this kid you know broke this other
kids nose and the only reason why he got
a black eyes cuz it took a couple of the
other kids friends to come in and sucker
him right so good for him
good for him that was his first like
prison sort of experience you know and
he did what he needed to do to not get
assaulted further sorna's fast-forward
to later that afternoon my wife and I
were called into the school office where
her son and the other boy with his
parents were waiting we had a
conversation with the school counselor
during the conference the other boy's
dad was extremely pissed off and
literally wanted to sue me know Jesus
you know isn't that amazing
it's just people they love their kids so
much they can't even see where they they
kind of got what they deserved
anyways he said at least this is this
guy's version of it anyways he said I
was calm and I politely asked him to
relax at that point this dad wanted to
fight me once the council calmed the
room down this dad muttered under his
breath while facing the counselor he's
lucky he's lucky we're here or else I
would hurt that son of a [ __ ] now Jesus
I immediately responded with what did
you say the dad didn't turn his glance
away from the counselor but smirk and
responded quiet
saying you heard me [ __ ] now Jesus I
love when people say yeah you're lucky I
didn't have to go home to my mom or else
something would have happened I
immediately lost it because I can't
stand passive-aggressive [ __ ] I asked if
he wanted to take it outside but he kept
smiling and nodding his head he then
looked at his beaten up child and said
you see son don't ever turn out like
this [ __ ] right here while pointing
at me I'll do right there that just made
me want to rip his throat out dude you
took the bait though man you took the
[ __ ] bait he totally said that [ __ ]
just to make you flip out you know what
this guy's like this guy's like a Claude
Lemieux except he can't make you win a
cup you know he's basically doing that
[ __ ] when the ref isn't looking and then
you're retaliating and then he's making
you look like a douche so anyways he
goes I immediately lost my [ __ ] because
I can't stand pastor president but uh my
wife grabbed my arm and asked me to
please sit back down your conference
ended shortly after that and the two
boys were suspend - the next day for
fighting yeah in the future sir just
like when someone is being
passive-aggressive you just don't react
to it it's unbelievably hard and I don't
know how to do it but I'm really good
about giving advice I mean now that I'm
sitting here calmly as the Monday Monday
morning podcast quarterback here you
know the second subarray he's lucky
we're in here you know that unless you
can just be like just say to you son oh
yeah that we're lucky were in here or
else this guy would have done something
thank god this 140 pound guidance
counselor on the other side of a desk is
stopping this guy from turning into a
superhero whew I'm counting my lucky
stars hey thank God this carpeting on
the floor that this was just regular
tile I would be in trouble that's it I
mean just throw it right back at him
just actually agree with what he's
saying
it completely sarcastically that usually
diffuses that kind of stuff so anyways
the conference ended shortly afterwards
and the two boys were suspended the next
day for fighting since then I now notice
that that [ __ ] dad and his kid every
morning while dropping my kids off at
school I wouldn't care about a few days
ago I caught this prick telling his kid
to stay away from that little piece
[ __ ] and he was referring to my son what
is worse is that the baseball season is
starting up and I overheard my son
telling his buddy that he and the other
kid are on the same team I need your
help bill I just know this dad is gonna
start some [ __ ] during the some game or
practice I can only imagine my son
striking out or dropping the ball and I
hear that [ __ ] guy saying something
out loud all right this is the deal this
guy so when you head at this point like
you're anticipating [ __ ] that he's gonna
do alright this is the deal at the end
of the day your son kicked his son's ass
alright so that's why this guy's acting
like the [ __ ] that he's acting like cuz
that's all he can say all right and if
he was gonna do something to you he
would have done something to you but he
doesn't cuz he's an adult and he doesn't
want to get sued and you're not gonna do
anything to him because you don't wanna
get sued and you shouldn't alright so
all he's doing is he's running his yep
so who gives a [ __ ] the great thing here
is is if you don't take his bait and you
just lay back or whatever both those
kids your son and his son they're gonna
be on the same team they're gonna work
it out how many [ __ ] childhood
friendships start that way the first
time you see each other you hate each
other you duke it out and then like
[ __ ] three days later you're you know
you're playing baseball together this is
this is classic they're probably gonna
become best of friends this is one of
these things where you have to do the
hardest thing in life which I feel is
one of the hardest things emotionally I
should say is you got to be the bigger
man alright look at this guy's insecure
as hell
your son kicked his son's ass and you
know he's humiliated on some level I
guess so now all he's trying to do is
make you [ __ ] mad and you taking the
bait so in a way he's kind of winning so
just stop taking the bait let him say
what the [ __ ] he's gonna say you know I
don't know I mean I don't know I don't
know how to do it
honestly I'm not wired emotionally like
that I can easily tell you not to take
the bait but I have to admit if he said
something to me
I would just be I mean uh I would have
everything my power not to say I'm sorry
my son kicked your son's ass but then
you're talking [ __ ] for your son and
then it becomes a problem you just got
to be the bigger man all right and I
don't know this whole [ __ ] thing went
off the rails you both love your sons
neither one of them you want to see your
kids get hurt and this guy's acting like
a [ __ ] kid himself and yeah you got
to be the bigger guy here ah this one
sucks dude I feel for you man I don't
know what to tell you I don't know what
to tell you I can tell you a bunch of
dumb things to do you know and you've
already fantasized about them as you
screamed at your windshield pretending
you were talking to him has you
fantasized about what catching him on
the morning going out to get his
newspaper be like how about now huh you
can kick my ass now right want to do
that and watch the [ __ ] paper right
down his throat you know what you guys
got to stop sending me these stories
because I've kind of lived vicariously
through them and they like they really
they really bother me that really
[ __ ] bothers me you know what I think
it's a good time right now to talk about
hockey one of the great sports out there
and for all you people who say why do
they allow why do they let them fight
you know why they let him fight so you
can't have any douchebags like this in
the league people get to act like the
tough when they're really not
you know because eventually you get
yours you know Tie Domi eventually
clocked Ulf Samuelsson and I loved it
you know Claude Lemieux eventually
turtled right I actually think Claude
was a tough guy he just that guy I don't
know that guy is one of the guys I can
never make my mind up about I just
thought he was such a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] but god dammit that son of a [ __ ]
was a winner the guy want a cup on three
different teams
you just can't freeze the only guy who
played that way that I can give a pass
to do you guys ever see that that video
when he was sitting on the he's sitting
on the bench and somebody got checked in
to the bench and the guy was like you
know doubled over so is his head was was
over the board's in the opposing
basically opposing teams been
area and Claude Lemieux and in the other
play who's on the ice is leaning on him
so the guy can't get up and Claude
Lemieux just looks down and when the ref
isn't looking he just winds up and
clocks this dude in the [ __ ] head
it was one of the dirtiest it was so
dirty you just laughed it was just such
a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] move
but there was something about him the
end of the day the guy could play put
the [ __ ] puck in the net who do you
want it with avalanche Canadiens
Canadiens in 93 I want to say the
Avalanche in 96 Devils in 95 or 2000 I
can't remember
anyways I feel for you sir I would just
let the let the kids hash it out and if
the guy says anything just walk up to
him say listen dude who's kidding who we
both know if you were gonna hit me you
would have by now all right you're not
gonna all right so just let it go
that would probably spark something oh
my god I I wouldn't be able to do it if
I was standing with me and somebody was
saying that if he if he ran his mouth I
would just be like oh hey that's that
guy that said I'm lucky the guidance
counselor's here or else he'd be kicking
my ass
anybody here see that guidance counselor
gee how come he's not kicking my ass
what am i lucky about now what did that
trees over there am i lucky that there's
a tree there because if that tree wasn't
there you'd be kicking my ass what you
gotta say that passive-aggressive if
you're gonna keep stopping you're not
gonna look at me are you you're gonna
sit this you know maybe that's why your
son such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
throwing a basketball my son's head you
know he broke broke your kids nose you
do realize that don't you don't you well
why don't you sue me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry at some point I gotta get the
anger out I get like angry about that
the [ __ ] is wrong with me yeah dude you
got to be the bigger man you gotta you
gotta be you got to be the bigger man
you I don't know what you know what you
should do whenever the guy talk [ __ ]
just think about the fact that your son
broke
his son's nose and somehow try and
convey that with the smile on your face
maybe you should say that just be hey
listen man I just want to be friends I
just want you know I'm concerned for you
how is your son's nose is he breathing
properly again oh that would be the dumb
thing to do sir the proper there the big
thing to do is just to be the the bigger
man but oh my god no listen don't don't
anticipate him saying anything I I'm
gonna I'm willing to bet that they're
gonna end up being friends and you know
what coach's son tell him to be a good
teammate all right tell him to cheer
nice and loudly and root for that other
kid that he broke his nose telling a
root form when he's up at bat all right
and when he gets a hit tell him you know
nice play or something like that okay
and through the wonderment and the magic
of sports they'll become friends all
right
and that'll be great and then one day
your son will go over their house and
there's and he'll laugh they'd actually
be a nice guy looking at your sons right
or left hand wondering which was the one
that smashed his son's face who knows
and maybe in the end you guys end up
being friends um who knows who knows
that's how it works out in sitcom land
good luck with that sir that is a
podcast for this week oh I forgot to
bring up the wonderful skate fenders
calm guys I cannot say enough about this
product if you play hockey and who likes
taking a nice slap shot off the foot I
know I don't how many times you gone out
you're all excited you had a bad day at
work right you're having problems with
your girl maybe you don't have a girl
right you got some aggression you want
to get it out you get out on the ice and
you [ __ ] two shifts out there
somebody [ __ ] nails you in the foot
with the puck and the skate and then you
feel he got shot in the foot you limp
off and the whole nights over the next
day you got a limp into work sucks right
would it be great if somebody came up
with some protection for your feet that
was lighter than a goddamn sock and you
wouldn't even notice when you wore it
well the people at skate fenders calm
are excited to announce skate fenders
they fit right over the butea skate and
they're injected and molded of
high-grade lightweight impact resistant
polycarbonate that protect the feet of
hockey players it's effective in
reducing painful debilitating impact
injuries they're convenient for players
to put
to put on and take off yeah I've
actually used these already and you can
put them on and take them off in two
seconds you don't even notice that
you're wearing them they don't slow you
down at all all it does is make you foot
not hurt when you get hit with the puck
I mean you definitely know you got hit
I'm not gonna lie to you you definitely
know you got hit but like it feels like
you know when it would you know like
somebody just took a little wrist shot
and hit you shin guard you keep playing
you're a hockey player right well 19 out
of the 30 teams in the NHL are using
these things and for some reason it says
including the Detroit Red Wings like as
a Bruins fan I'm supposed to like you
know how about the Boston Bruins show a
couple people over there using them
anyways they're affordable to all
players at all levels if you use the
bill burr promo code you'll get five
dollars off basically go to order them
it'll ask if you have a promo code any
type in my name bill burr all lowercase
no spaces and you will get five dollars
off your your skate fenders and I'm
gonna tell you something first time you
take a puck and it hits one of those
those those damn fenders there's gonna
be a smile on your face and you can be
like I can't believe I ever didn't wear
these things at least that's how I felt
and lastly amazon.com if you're thinking
about buying anything on amazon.com not
saying but if you're thinking about it
if you like to help me out go to go to
my website bill burr com click on the
podcast page you'll see right underneath
the iTunes logo you'll see the what do
you call it the window whatever you see
the amazon thing just go to amazon
through then through through that thing
that you click on the banner the amazon
banner on the podcast page of my website
that's what i was trying to say and then
go there and buy something if you want
to if you do they give me a little
kickback and whatever i get i take 10%
of it and i give it to the Wounded
Warriors Project a great cause
you'll be helping out the podcast and
even more importantly you'll be helping
out the Wounded Warriors Project and
those of you in Canada in the UK next
week I'll have links on amazon.com for
fans in those countries and tell you
what once you guys give me some sort of
charity over there you know up
Canada what should I give money to the
Starbucks that you burned down every
time you don't win the Stanley Cup sorry
cheap shot or what over in Canada how
about I give to some group that wants to
investigate the Rothschild family give
me some sort of charity over there and
we'll send them are worthless US dollars
how about that all right
that's the podcast for this week um
[Music]
let's see shows I have coming up shows
I'm on vacation until March the 30th
well out when I will be at the DuPont
theater in Wilmington Delaware March
31st I'll be at the Music Hall in Troy
New York they still have the cloud9
titty bar out there I went to one and I
went that a long friggin time ago good
time and on April 1st I'll be at the
Music Hall in Tarrytown New York please
please please please come out to those
shows and you'll see a little bit of my
last hour and hopefully the first 1015
in my first my next hour and once again
thanks to everybody came out to my show
and uh at the Lincoln Theater in DC I
had a great time and that's it that's
the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves don't take any [ __ ] hope you
continue to listen and I really want to
hear from that woman that wrote me that
scathing email all right I want you I
want you to address women that do that
okay and I want I want to know why you
feel as though I'm talking about all
women when I'm clearly just talking
about women who do that and how that you
feel that me making fun and calling
women [ __ ] who cheat on their husbands
have babies with other guys and then
make their husband pay for it why you
think that if I say that they're [ __ ]
that that somehow is the same thing as
trashing black people you know who went
through slavery for the love of God can
you please bridge those two thoughts
because I find that more confusing than
how a plane gets off the ground and
stays up there all right that's it go
[ __ ] yourself
you